このビデオを後援してくれたhellotalkに感謝します。みなさん、こんにちは
。今日は日本人教師の第4話を歓迎します。今日は
、1人の日本人だけを見ていきます。それ
には特別な
理由がありますが、 すぐにそれに
入るので、今日はシュサンの日本語を見ていきます
ので
、私たちを見始めましょう
日本の教師の成績は
日本語ですあなたの日本語について最初に言いたいの
は、特に
音声的に本当に本当に良い
と思います あなたの
発音は驚異
的だと私は冗談ではありませんが、
あなたの発音はおそらく
私の発音よりも優れていると思う
ので、高低アクセントに関連するいくつかのことを修正できれば
、
全体的にあなたの話している日本語は
もっと聞こえると思います ええと、物事の発音の側面について話す直前に私の話した日本語よりも自然です
iiは
、ビデオでそれを考えていると言いたいです 最初はもっと
丁寧な日本語
でしたが、途中で
言ったと思い
ますので、もっとカジュアルな日本語に切り替えて
みました。明らかに日本語の要素があるので、これに気づいてみてください。
発音やピッチの
振る舞い、そして日本人が
それを聞くと不自然
に聞こえますが、それ以上に、
ほとんどの日本人は
おそらく
礼儀正しい日本人からカジュアルな日本人
への切り替えを意識して
いると思います。 あなたの日本語は
確かに
私が話していることを知るのに十分ですので、それは私が知っている
ことの1つです。
ええと、それは
一種のポイントですが
、物事の音声面に取り掛かりましょう。これは
、私が
意図的に
あなたのビデオを選んだので、私が今本当に興奮しているところです。 彼が初めて
見たのはツイッターで見た私
は
あなたがビデオの単語の1つを
間違った方法
でインクで言ったことに気づきました この種の単語を二度と誤解することはありません。
これは、私がパトレオンで教えている
非常に重要な
音声ピッチアクセントルールの1つです。
これは、
これを覚えるルールです。
これは、非常に高い割合で覚えるようになりました。
4つのマウラの割合が非常に高いので
、
2つの漢字または中国語の文字
を含む日本語の4つのビート名詞の種類は、ピッチアクセントパターンがフラットであるため
、ハーバンピッチアクセントパターンを持っている
ため、
よりゆっくりとしたより慎重なスピーチで
は、ゆっくりと始まります 少し上に行くと
、単語全体でほぼフラットになりますが、通常の
日常のスピーチでは、このパターンは
基本的にあなたのビデオでは基本的にフラット
です。 このように綴られた教育用の単語を言ったので、
今すぐ画面に
表示します
が、単語の最初に言ったと思いますが、これは
これに該当する単語の完璧な例です。
このルールでは、
漢字が2つ、漢字が
4つある
ので、京は2つの文字
がありますが、京は1ビートだけで、
1ビートは1ビートを食べ
、さらに
1ビートはさらに4つの漢字
名詞です。 実際には
kyoykoではなく、多かれ少なかれフラットな
ので、実際にはそうではありませんが
、多かれ少なかれフラットであり、
このパターン
に分類される非常に多くの単語があります。この単一のパターン
を知るだけで
、正しい発音が正しい
ピッチアクセントであることがすぐにわかります。
この1つの規則を知っているだけで、文字通り何百もの日本語の
日常名詞が、この
規則に該当するためにこの規則に従う日常の規則の束の小さなリストのようなものになりました。 の
構造とこの高低
アクセントもあるので
、今すぐこのリストを下に移動しましょう。
学校の
ように大学の
ように高校のように学生の
ように勉強のように銀河のように銀行の
ように最悪または最低のサヤクの
ように 警察署のように最悪のコバン
、実際のシンバイのように心配
して文字通り何百も正確な数はわかりませんが、
確か
にこのパターンに分類され、この単語構造を持つ他の100の名詞は少なくとも100以上の
高低アクセントパターンを持っています 同様に、
私がちょうどこのパターンに該当すると言った日常の名詞の数を聞くことによって、
それは一種の
驚異的な権利ですそれは一種
のちょっと待っているようなものですそれは学では
ありませんがそれは大学ではありません
高低アクセントは、
4つのモーラと2つの
カンジを持つ日本語の名詞がこのパターンに該当すると想定し
てい
ます。この規則には例外が
ありますが、単語が非常に多いため、私は高度に言います。
この規則
に従うと、一般的な
日常の例外を覚えて
、その例外に含まれない他のすべての単語
が規則に従うと仮定でき
ます。
そうすると、日本語の発音の打率の
平均
がすぐに再び増加します。 この単一のルールを知って話す
と、話す日本語の自然さがすぐに向上する
ので
、今すぐいくつかの例外を見てみましょう。
これは、モーラと2つの漢字
の場合ですが、私がしなかっ
た場合は、それほど音楽ではありません。
兄弟先生のように、先生のように京大
は先生ではなく、先生でもありません。給料のように不幸なクディオのように
ザーンネンを見せたり案内したりするのは先生です。
申し訳ありませんが、日本
の家の誰かの家への入り口のように、3
つか4つの一般
的なものを
書き忘れてしまいました。 私が今リストしたばかりのイオン私は
基本的に
、日本語で2つの漢字を持つ他の4つの名詞すべて
がこのちょっと爆弾のパターンに分類
されると仮定するのが安全
だと信じています。 特に英語を母国語とする人にとっては、文字通り
何百もの日常の名詞が
間違っているように
、あなたはこれらすべての
単語を
ガクセや
日本語の話し言葉のように
言ってきました。 おそらくほとんどの
日本人とあなたは本当に
このルールをあなたの骨に取り入れ
たいと思います。いわば
、あなたの
話し言葉が私の話し言葉よりも良く聞こえるポイントに
すぐに到達すると思います。前述のように、ハロートークは
これを後援しました ビデオなので
、数分かけて、hellotalkが言語学習アプリケーションであること
を知らない人のために彼らのサービスを紹介し
ます。
その言語のネイティブスピーカーと直接対話すること
は過去に少し話しましたが、
非常に長い間
、language8.comというサービスを使用し
ました。そのウェブサイトでは
、日本語で何かを書くことになります。
そして、日本語を母国語とする人が
それ
を修正し、次に
英語のハロートークを修正するのはその
ようなものですが、実際に
日本語を話す自分を録音して、
基本的に即座に直接母国語の入力を得ることができる
ので、非常に価値があると思います。 今
からやってみるの
は
、前に言った5つの単語を正しい
高低アクセントで少し録音して
、間違った高低アクセントで言って、ネイティブスピーカーを取得できるかどうかを確認してみましょう。
それらを修正するために
、マイクをクリックして、
録音用の
大学の
ダイゴンを少し作成します。これ
を今すぐ投稿
して、ネイティブのreを取得するのにかかる時間を確認します。 スポンジは私が応答を受け取った
ようです私は
ビデオを投稿してから10分後に応答を受け取りました
日本語の話者が数人います
すべての単語の高低アクセントを下げて
、この男は実際
に正しい
ええと日本語のアクセントとすべての単語の録音をしたので
、東京のアクセントで発音したい場合
は、サイコである必要がある
ので、すぐに聞いてみましょう。 これがさらに4つの
ルールです。
これは、日本語の高低アクセントと発音を
積極的に改善しようとしている人々にとって非常に価値が
あります。自動翻訳などの非常に優れた機能がたくさんあり、長い単語を保持でき
ます。 それは日本語で、
日本語を勉強し始めたばかりで
、カンジとヒラガナがまだ読めない場合は、マジのないローマ字に切り替わります。
明らかに非常に便利で、
無料で使用できます。また、特別なvip
アカウントもあるので、いくつかの特典
があり
ますが、特にまだ行っていない場合は、少なくともアプリケーションをチェックする
ことをお勧めします。 日本語を勉強していて、日本語
を上達させようとしている
ので、
ハロートークをチェックしてください。このビデオを後援してくれたハロートークにもう一度感謝します。
日本語の靴に戻りましょう
。あなたがすでにそれを言い始めているという良い証拠があります。
あなたはすでに日本語のアクセントをよく理解しています。
それは、ビデオに
少なくとも1つの単語があったため
です。
ほとんどのネイティブ英語話者は
、あなたのネイティブ英語話者または少なくとも
英語が最初の言語の1つ
だと思います。 あなたは明らかに英語のエリアであるトロントに戻ったと言いましたが、あなたは
日本語
とほとんどのネイティブの英語話者のビデオの単語であるええと言いました
udied pageアクセント
は、この単語をdolga dolgaと発音します。
アクセント付きのドルガ
は、単語の先頭で失礼します。
これは
、前に説明した規則に該当する単語
の例ではありませんが
、次の単語の例
です。 これ
は、2、3のビデオで紹介した一般的なカテゴリに分類されます。つまり
、日本語の3つのモーラ名詞の約半分にはアクセントがないため
、ヘボンである
ため、再びドーガではありません。
正しい方法であるとおっしゃいました。 ですから、
あなたはすでに給料の面でまともなスタートを切って
います、そして私
はあなたがあなたのアクセントではなくあなたが言ったことによってあなたがそうではなかったように聞こえる前にそれを勉強したことがないと思い
ます
私が今説明したルール
とあなたは
この
絶対に信じられないほどの場所にいるでしょうそしてあなたは
あなたの発音を超えていますあなたは
本当に本当に自然な方法であなたの考えを明確に表現しています
そしてそのような1つの非常に
小さなマイナーなことを除いて いつ  あなたは
、私が言うことになるもう一つのことがあるのを見たのですが、それは
あなたのように私にも聞こえました 今は全体的にアクセントのある
日本語の単語を言っていたのですが
、以前の動画で
話していたので、
実際にレッスン1で話したとは思いません。
以下にリンクを残しておきますので、もし人々が元気になりたい
のなら、それは日本語ではなく
、
多かれ少なかれまた別の言葉なので、
下にそのビデオへのリンクを残します
が、あなたが離れている曲をもう一度撮影します
信じられないほどのスタートです。今のところ
うまくいっていれば、今日紹介
した1つのルールを覚えることに集中
してください。そうすれば、すぐに
絶対に信じられないほどの場所
にいることになります。特に、
このルールは
とてもわかりやすいので、 もう一度
、ルールを学ぶだけで基本的に一晩ですぐに日本語を
上達させるので、このビデオでビデオを終了するつもりだと思います。
主
に漢字の名詞ルールの公式をカバーしたかった
のです。
ツイッターで聞いたの
ですが、これは
とても重要なルールを紹介する絶好の機会だと思いました。このルールを覚えている人は誰でも
、できるだけネイティブに聞こえたい場合は非常に重要です。
日本語を音声で分析して
、dogan dogenのtwitterでビデオを送って
ください。すぐに視聴できるようにビデオを埋め込んで
ください。また、ダウンロードリンクを提供
して、元の品質の元のバージョンをダウンロードできるようにしてください。
ええと、今日本語を学び
始めたばかりの人
や多分
彼らに役立つ字幕を追加することもできれば ちなみに
何が起こっているのかを正確に理解するのは
難しいので、次のビデオ
は通常のコメディスタイルのビデオに戻るので、それを
期待して
、ありがとうございます もう一度、
このビデオを後援してくれた
hellotalkに感謝します。ここで終わります。これから
も
よろしくお願いします。今後ともよろしくお願いいたします
。またお会いしましょう。